so let's get started spent a few nights
preparing these slides so i'll talk
about bitcoin talk about China why
bitcoin is popular in China and also
talk about my my journey in China I've
been living in shanghai now for the last
nine years I used to live in the US and
how I started btcc and share with you
some thoughts on that so how many here
know about Bitcoin yes finally finally
the vast Magoo room raised their hand
three years ago I would ask it would be
like crickets chirping no silence
completely so this is great so how many
of the actual own Bitcoin how about that
a few of you in the front row that's
great so let's get started so so bitcoin
is actually many things to many people I
say it's just like the internet because
the Internet is used in different ways
by different people all around the world
and for me bitcoin is also like that
many of you know Bitcoin maybe you heard
about in the media some of you even own
a transact in Bitcoin but I think the
truth will come out over time about how
bitcoin is really used for the society
so let's talk about let's go back and
talk about why I think bitcoin is great
let's go back to the internet days so
think about digital information why is
digital information great so where I
look at it is for the first time when
the internet came about we can now
transmit information transmitted
messages in real time instantly without
third parties involved and also
practically for free so this is why I
call the the faster better cheaper right
when something is truly faster better
cheaper that's when its revolutionary it
changes the world so with digital
information with electronics and
computers we now have information at the
speed of light so before that with Pony
Express or even postal mail to transmit
a message even across the Atlantic Ocean
it could take days or weeks am i right
so that's why communication was very
limited to small communities and
anything outside you don't know what
what's going on the rest of the world
with the internet we can now have
information at your fingertips and this
has been going for the last 20 years by
the way right but this is the the best
part is that the digital aspect it's a
digital aspect of information that
allows for all
this breakthrough faster better cheaper
so what about Bitcoin how is
bitcoin-related so a lot of people say
bitcoin is related it's kind of like the
internet was 20 years ago and I truly
believe that so I'm very excited so now
instead digital information of digital
assets and digital assets is even better
than digital information because now you
can have real value transfer it over at
the speed of light right real value
think about that what this means okay
it's also instant it's also no third
parties and lower costs it's so it's
same thing faster better cheaper but
what we have now is real value being
transferred what I mean by that is this
is the precursor to teleportation I'm
getting ahead of myself here we have
teleportation here we don't we don't
have it yet but with the ingenuity of
humanity i think you know you know maybe
in a lifetime or not we will have
teleportations like the Star Trek's but
this is as close as we'll get because we
can now send something truly valuable in
real time across the internet anywhere
in the world so it's not just
information but something real value so
let's say you have a tesla car you want
to send it can you send a tesla china
now you could because you could actually
encapsulate the price of the Tesla
vehicle and send it by bit coin over and
then they can receive it the recipient
can receive it in China and use that
money to pay for and buy a Tesla and
drive it off the lot does that make
sense so this is why I say it's close to
teleportation because with that you can
even have instructions with that you can
even higher you can even pay from
someone in China to go and do the dirty
work I'm actually buying and bringing
the car to you so with enough Bitcoin
you could send it out there and someone
will do it and give it the Tesla to the
recipient okay so its real value at the
speed of light so a little bit more
about Bitcoin so this is may be
confusing to some of you but what I mean
by this is information now has value
okay its definitive transferable value
so before that let me go back one one
before i show that word information was
always valuable if i take some pictures
i can share with you wow that's great i
could you sharing on instagram or
facebook but it's not definitive nor is
it transferable meaning by share
photographs all I'm doing is I'm making
multiple copies i'm sharing with hundred
people a thousand people right same
thing with this video with with this etl
talk probably recorded probably streamed
later on for on youtube and so on on
stanford's a corner but it's not
transferable value it's not like I'm
giving it to you and therefore you have
it I don't have it but with Bitcoin this
is what we have for the first time in
humanity we now have a digital currency
that is information based da information
based digital currency right but has
definitive transferable value that means
that i can give you some of my digital
currency for you to have it of which I
no longer have it and this mimics the
physical reality physical world where I
can give you a glass of beer and you
will have it I don't have it anymore
does that make sense so this is the the
really cool thing and this is real this
really big deal is this is real this is
not hocus pocus this is not virtual
currencies of the 1980s 1990s okay we're
talking about crypto currencies that's
what bitcoin is different so it's become
valuable what do you guys think yes no I
have a let me pull it out I've pre
release of a new physical bitcoin that
BTCC will be selling in about two weeks
I won't tell you too much about its
pre-release but this is valuable if I
toss it over to you I've essentially
given you access
nice one if you toss me some US dollars
what we can do that exchange yeah but
this is um in this case it's physical I
could toss it to you and then it'll be
physical you catch it right but but it's
truly valuable because once I tossed it
to you it's out of my hands and that's
what bitcoin does electronic we go we
made in physical format why is this
valuable other than the piece of metal
well because a few things it's got
uniquely great features so until Bitcoin
was invented nothing in the world was
able to encapsulate the functionality
the the sort of the feature set the
Bitcoin gave us we're a physical we
could give you money gold give you
stocks or bonds give you a house and so
on or title to a house but with Bitcoin
now we can have a global network for
payments with the fixed supply of
bitcoins 21 million of which this is one
we can have a decentralized payment
decentralized nature of it what that
means is the Bitcoin that I give you
let's say does not depend on some
company telling you how many bitcoins
you own does it make sense so for the
first time you can now have Bitcoin that
is truly truly decentralized from any
other company now even though our
company my company BTCC we run a bitcoin
exchange bitcoin wallet service and all
that we are a centralized service but
even if our company goes away or there
is no bitcoin company you can still own
Bitcoin without depending on any other
central government any sort of a
university or any sort of company okay
and of course very low fees so this is
truly faster better cheaper so why I
like big point to summarize for the
first time we actually have a digital
asset think about that all the assets
you own everyone in this room other than
the ones of the few of you who own
Bitcoin all of your assets all the
things you own that you've worked hard
for in your life or physical in nature
the other types of assets are intangible
like for example your Stanford education
or your knowledge about the world
right but any other tangible assets
always always physical in nature
everything from the money you own have
you to wallet the precious metals gold
and silver the stocks and bonds even
real estate or physical nature right
some of you do any of you own domain
names yes so domain name comes close but
email addresses actually are not digital
assets would all of you have email
accounts but you don't own them right a
moment's notice gmail can stop your
account or lock you out or iCloud apple
icloud could right so you don't own your
email just anymore then it's more like a
permission for you to use it okay domain
names you sort of owned them but it's at
the mercy of the domain name
registration companies they could make a
mistake or they could take away from you
right and what if I I've heard some
horror stories of domain names but the
point is none of you if you don't own
Bitcoin or digital cryptocurrencies none
of your own digital assets don't we
already live in a internet digital age
yes who still live in the Stone Age so
given that we live in digital age the
bitcoin is very important Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies very important because
for now we really have digital assets
okay second thing is it's not just any
digital assets it's not just you know
seashells or peanuts or pieces of rice
or candies because this is a strictly
limited and scarce digital asset 20
million 21 million sounds like a lot but
in the grand world things it's actually
comes down to about 0.003 per person in
the world right it's only 31 thousands
per person if you spread it all around
seven billion people so what happens is
Bitcoin was actually created down to
eight decimal places so you have a
hundred million units in each Bitcoin so
just that way people could use it in
smaller things so that's what I call for
each pick one we call 1 million bits
okay so that's why it's even though
that's a lot but it's still scarce in
limited no one can make more bitcoins
does that make sense you cannot print
them no company can issue more big
and so they can issue virtual currencies
so for example how many of you belong to
airline frequent flyer miles hotel
reward points yeah so those points you
have there actually are centralized by
the companies right that's why no one in
the right mind would spend their
allowance or spend their monthly
paycheck to buy more airline miles or do
any of you do that do you buy more hotel
points they ask they always offered it
also hey you want to buy more miles I'm
like yeah right and the reason I say
that is because the airline miles are
ultimately controlled and configured by
the airlines and they can do whatever
they want they can increase the
redemption price they could make it
invalid they can say your miles don't
expire and then a few years later they
said models do expire you know they
change the rules on you but with a
decentralized cryptocurrency that will
never happen okay so if you own for
example 21 bitcoins then you always have
at least one millionth of the supply of
the whole world's Bitcoin okay so lastly
those two features if it being digital
and being scarce it actually makes for a
good payment system so today bitcoin is
not yet the world's best payment system
right you have really good payment
systems like PayPal in China there's a
leap a there's WeChat pay there's venmo
in the u.s. right there's a lot of good
payment systems around the world already
or even just physical cash bitcoin is
not yet the most revolution is that yes
the best payment system we don't use it
to buy coffee yet but bitcoin has a
potential because of it being a great
digital currency okay so for me that's a
bonus and that's why I like Bitcoin okay
so now let's talk about let's talk about
China that's how about China so I live
in China now I started BTC China
co-founded it used to be called BTC
China and I was called BTCC so it turns
out I didn't know at the time that
Bitcoin was going to be really big in
China I just did the startup because I
thought Bitcoin was really interesting
and since I was physically in China I
thought I should do it in China and not
go to Africa or something and it turned
out China was great it was like made in
heaven in terms of its adoption in that
in that so bitcoin is really big in
China now the question is is that China
itself or is it really big coin that's
really
popular so let's go through that a
little bit okay so China is crazy about
Bitcoin you guys may not know this but
Chinese really crazy about Bitcoin
mining is huge okay Trading is huge so
mining mining is a process of making
bitcoins from scratch so if you think
about the 21 million i'll talk about
them a little bit so that's called
Bitcoin mining trading is the notion of
vine selling bitcoins some people trade
for profit i'll talk about that and then
let's talk about why okay why is Bitcoin
so popular in china so so Bitcoin mining
have you heard of this phrase before how
many of you have no idea what bitcoin
mining is raise your hand all right Wow
okay so it sounds kind of odd I have
this picture of this open open what do
they call it Oh bit yeah big pit open
pit mining this is actually not Bitcoin
mining we had we had an April Fool's
video this year that that try to depict
Bitcoin mining as with the shovel you
can go watch it online but this is
actually not Bitcoin mining but I just
use it as a background but what is
Bitcoin mining Bitcoin mining is really
popular in China and before if I go go
there here's what it is okay think about
if you were the secret creative Bitcoin
and you said let's only have 21 million
bitcoins how do you decide who should
have the 21 million bitcoins is there a
good answer they should all give it to
me or they should give it to all the
poor people in Africa or maybe only give
it to Americans or give it just to the
men or the woman right or just the
children or just the Internet enabled
people or just people who have driver's
license how do you do that for something
that's digital an Internet global how
did decide who to give the 21 million
bitcoins it was a big big question and
there was no easy answer however what he
thought was this guy satoshi nakamoto he
thought that the best way is to give it
out for free for free for everyone who
wants to get Bitcoin ok so I'll talk
about that so bitcoins really popular in
China so it turns out a lot of Chinese
people love Bitcoin so a lot of Chinese
feel apart are participating in this
process of getting pick one for free so
I think over a clearly over sixty
percent even seventy percent of
share4 from mining for Bitcoin now how
does it work it's actually free lottery
so what the inventor decided was Satoshi
said that we can give it back on for
free all you have to do is come on over
run the software click on a button and
do one simple math calculation it turns
out it's like a it's like a hashing
algorithm on the computer and if you do
one hashing algorithm what one run you
wouldn't run hash then we give you one
lottery ticket so I'll be all these
dozens of lottery tickets right so in
the beginning he was only one doing it
so he would press a button he gets one
lottery ticket now there's only one law
to get in the bowl guess what he wins
the first lottery ticket right so this
polluted process when more people
participate then you could you each get
lottery tickets and turns out he's
giving off these big coin prizes at
every 10 minutes so every 10 minutes
there's a free Bitcoin 50 bitcoins /
lottery winner and then every hour
there's six winners and every day
there's 144 and each day there was 7,200
bitcoins being given away for free so
for the first four years he gave away
about 10 million bitcoins like that so
if you do 7,200 bitcoins a day times
four years of 365 days that's about 10
million bitcoins that's how bitcoins
came into the world through this free
lottery so i put it asterisks they're
free is it really free why not is this
etl lecture free is it free it's not did
you guys pay an entrance fee then I
collect something from you as you give
me some bitcoins well it's free with an
asterisk because you have to expend the
energy to come here or if you're viewing
online you have to expend the energy to
download the video to watch it same
thing with Bitcoin you can get these
lottery tickets for free as long as you
expend the energy the computation to do
these math hashes mathematical hashes
and what happens is we're not talking
about just doing a few hashes after is
people realize it's so good deal you
could just keep doing more so people
started doing 100 hashes per second a
thousand hashes per second they cook up
multiple computers to do it and they use
graphics cards and specialized chips and
now these days they're special computers
I'm sorry special come
that makes specialized ASIC chips
application-specific i sees that does
bitcoin mining and they do they don't do
these chips don't do thousands of hashes
per second not even millions not even
billion they do trillions of hashes per
second the whole world today has like
200 what is it 200 I think I thinks
2,400 pet two hashes per second a pet
hash is like a quadrillion hashes per
second and it was huge so with fast chip
assembly with fast electronics assembly
in China and really good chip design
people in China and also with chip
electricity Bitcoin mining is very very
popular in China for these reasons right
essentially you can make money out of
thin air you buy these machines
connected the wall to the power and you
get these free lottery tickets
eventually you win bitcoins okay so
today unfortunately it's no longer 50
big points per 10 minutes it's actually
25 bitcoins for 10 minutes and then the
schedule is actually this July there's
gonna be another having where the reward
for Bitcoin goes down further so come by
after july it's gonna be only 12 and a
half bitcoins for every 10 minutes which
is about 1,800 per day and that's how we
get slowly get to the 21 million
bitcoins okay so bitcoin mining is very
popular for these reasons let's go
quickly to trading okay training is
something interesting crazy stuff people
look at it as investing you could buy
sell bitcoin is investing you can also
look at it as speculation speculative
trading have you guys done that I
remember about 15 16 years ago or six
seventeen years ago in the Bay Area the
dot-com boom everybody was doing what
day trading all right you guys and any
of you doing that day trading stocks but
anyways so there's a lot of day trading
in China a lot of a lot of people buying
bitcoins they think it's going to go up
speculating value will go up and you
know it's also form of it's also
degenerate form of gambling so Chinese
people love to gamble the gamble on
stocks the gamble on real estate now
they can gamble and buy sell bitcoin so
trading is really big now one thing it's
not is that people ask me this all the
time so I might as well addressed it and
answer a question for you ahead of time
Bitcoin turned out in China is not about
evading capital control
in China there is there are capital
controls limiting how many how much
people can convert from the local
rubbing be currency to US dollars or
Euros but it turns out bitcoin is not a
great way because it's still a little
bit cumbersome to buy sell bitcoin and
also to properly do this you have to buy
the big coins in China's to send money
out and sell the bitcoins in Europe and
United States there's some lag time you
have to open accounts at the other
exchanges so so so they'll be cumbersome
some people do it in small scale but
this is not a great way to do to move
large amounts of money and plus there's
tons of loopholes in China anyways so
people can move the money using other
methods so what bitcoin is is for
Chinese people Bitcoin I would say is
about investing in the future right so
we have is it's a new revolutionary
global asset class the Chinese people
global people they realize that even
though they live in China the part of
the global world there's something I was
revolution is Bitcoin this is something
new so the way I see it is bitcoin is
truly a new digital asset class for a
digital age ok it's a digital asset for
a digital age that's that's why bitcoin
is popular in China ok so I'll take some
questions later but let me let me share
a little bit about my journey as
entrepreneur in China it turns out the
reason put it in quotes is I you know I
actually don't know what it's like being
an entrepreneur elsewhere because this
is a BTC see is the first company I
started in China so I'm going to share
with you a few things I've learned over
the years what do you guys think yeah ok
so they may not be China specific but
certainly you in the Q&A session you can
ask me more China specific stuff and in
some city almost wanted to say these are
seven things I didn't learn at Stanford
but that's actually not true that's why
I didn't put on the side because what
you'll see is without without talk about
I think most of you will know already
nothing nothing crazy but the reason I
say I learned is that i truly learn deep
down through experiencing it over the
last few years in China a lot of
concepts you know before but if you
don't practice it you don't you don't
really learn it so so let's get started
so number one in my job today I'm CEO in
my job
it's really about helping people succeed
okay so this is no surprise but the real
the wire the way I wanna hit home with
this point is that running company we're
about a hundred people now and why do I
say this because it's really about
making all of the hundred people really
succeed at the company only if they
succeed then we have a company that can
itself be successful because these days
the company is nothing without its
people so my role is almost like Chief
motivator right uh it's it's to really
help people so that they could succeed
in their own jobs in their own
responsibilities it's really that okay
so so if you ever get a chance to run a
company or even if you if you don't have
to be CEO for this to be true right even
if you're in a small project in a good
project at school if you can help your
classmates succeed then you will succeed
I guarantee you and then that's that's
how leadership happens right is the
willingness to go out and let someone
else succeed ok so number two this is
this not crazy either but its
willingness to give and accept what
critical feedback you could say advice
if it's critical feedback now I want to
spend a few minutes on this this very
this is very cool because I didn't
really take this to heart until recent
Allah until recently last few years what
I mean it's two things here it's to give
critical feedback and to accept it's
actually quite hard to give critical
feedback for many people all we want to
do is to show the happy face the happy
side of ourselves the nice side could be
well liked is that right how many of us
wants to be well liked Oh see shy okay
but but we all want to be well-liked
right we don't want to seem very
critical but but the fact of the matter
is if you if we cannot be critical of
certain things well if we can't be
candid it's like the candor topic that
Jack Walsh brings up right so when I
read that book I forgot the name of the
book but Jack Walsh wrote a famous book
in there one top it was candor in
organization
and only through running BTCC I've
learned this that is very important for
me to be able to give critical feedback
to my to my team members and likewise
it's also very difficult for people to
be on the receiving end so this is
something I encourage everyone the world
not just my team members but we really
have to learn to have thicker skin to to
have the ability to accept critical
feedback right how many of us go and go
out and ask for voluntarily asked for
critical feedback I bet most of you
don't do that certainly I didn't write
but these days in order for us to
succeed to change to adapt and to really
do well we have to have the ability and
the courage to go ask for critical
feedback we have to have the ability the
EQ to hold it in and to really accept
the critical feedback and if you're a
leader if you're even if you're a peer
the ability to actually go give critical
feedback okay so this is to me it's very
very important lesson I've learned okay
number three this the myth 2 3 4 are
actually related we talked about don't
complain have you heard of this before
yeah don't do you guys complain a lot so
if I have a picture of a little little
mouse in a block of cheese what do you
think is a glass-half-full at half empty
half full it's pretty good pretty good
place that turns out anything in life
you can complain about right if you're
in this little mouse can you complain
sure the cheese is not big enough the
hole is too small i'm stuck in here yeah
where are my utensils how come how come
how come there's no crackers to go with
the cheese right so so the point is you
can complain about everything but but
but this mouse is enact a pretty good
place so the reason I say don't complain
is in the end what I found is people who
complain put themselves in a position
where they feel like they can't do
anything they feel like they can't make
a difference but the realities of course
you can of course you can doesn't matter
if you work in a start-up it doesn't
matter if you work in large company does
Mac doesn't matter if you're just
student in the class or in a group
project of course you can make a
difference that's why are you here
that's why you're participating so if
you complain it naturally sends a signal
that the this has nothing to do with me
I can't do anything about it I want to
complain and you solve the problem for
me right rather the way I see the world
is that you can make a difference right
so instead of complaining give a
constructive feedback right so the other
thing is that complaining about the
situation won't change the situation
right because the past is history can
you change a pass can any of you change
the past I like to meet these time
travelers out there once in a while but
none of us can write as far as I am
concerned the other thing is so relative
that's why I have this mouse and the
cheese you know something that's bad for
a certain perspective can be good can be
viewed positively so every bad situation
you find yourself stuck in look at it
from the bright side look at from
optimistic side like the glass half full
side right and lastly have constructive
you have constructive feedback right
instead of saying this is a shitty
situation sorry shouldn't use bad words
this is a you know bad situation how do
I get out of it give these suggestions
give the give the ideas what you
recommend to do right in the end you are
your own boss right okay number four is
related as well no excuses all right do
you guys make excuses yes excuses so I
this is something it's one of those
things where you know you go through
school at Stanford but but then I didn't
really sink in until the last few years
so maybe maybe I'm just really dense so
now I'm 41 this year and I finally
starting to learn these things here's
what I mean okay do you know how you can
tell if something is an excuse my rule
of thumb of this okay when I talk to my
colleagues when they when when they miss
projects or when they when things don't
happen on time or on schedule or a
mistake happens and I asked him why like
why why did this thing happen like how
did this blow up or you know usually
something bad news right
it's always an excuse if they give you
the answer as you has do something else
outside outside their perspective
meaning anything that is external any
reason they give as external reasons is
an excuse think about that so what what
I mean by that is the truly no excuse
answer would be something about
themselves about yourself how come you
let that failure happen how come what
you did or what you didn't do allow for
that outcome and and this is it sort of
goes back to what I said earlier you
have to believe in yourself that you can
affect the outcome of situations does
that make sense for example so I'm
running a start-up now of course my
objective is to take our prop company
public right or to get sold for really
high valuation right to have an exit for
investors so years later let's say five
ten years later let's say I didn't do
that if I blame the market if I blame
the investors if i blame this and this
and that those are all excuses right in
the end if my company if we don't
succeed the only person that's
responsible is me right because if I'm
if I'm blaming other people then then
I'm just making up excuses so my point
is anything external is the excuse next
time you explain something you know ask
yourself you know oh what happened to my
homework example the dog ate it yeah
yeah I blame the dog right or why am I
why am i late this morning to work why
am i late to the meeting oh the alarm
clock didn't go off or like there's too
much traffic these are all external
reasons right so these are all excuses
so these days I don't accept excuses for
my team members I'm like nope that's
that's that's not allowed right only
when they actually truly admit reflect
on what they did or what they didn't do
themselves then they can learn and
improve and prevent the mistakes from
happening again okay so you heard about
the saying how janitors are allowed have
excuses but vice presidents are not have
you heard of this so VPS in our noggin
is in the organization but my
come by need not just VP's but managers
and above are not allowed to have
excuses only janitors are allowed to
have excuses okay basically for VP level
you should know everything is your
responsibility on night that's the
ultimate goal ok number five this is
related to the last few points this is
how I tell people I say don't let other
people's family or impact your success
so I say this in Chinese to my
colleagues in Chinese in China
essentially it comes down to meaning
sometimes when certain things don't
happen on time or properly they say oh
because I was waiting for someone else
or you know because this and this and
that did that right this person did that
thing and therefore this is the outcome
so those are all excuses right so I tell
them if you want to succeed and i tell i
would tell you as well if you want to
succeed don't let anyone elses failure
impact or limit your own success ok all
of you have what it takes to succeed in
your own ways whatever objective is
whether it's in class whether it's a
degree at stanford whether it's getting
the right job or the right career
becoming a doctor or anything or even
astronaut right you can you can succeed
as long as you don't let anyone else
step in your path and block your way so
don't ever let someone else their
failure or their mediocracy affect your
success ok so what what that means is
don't hang your success upon others ok
so really be happy and really go get it
do yourself ok now next topic is a fun
one and hit this I learned recently
again also in the last two years is it
turns out successful people actually do
have good habits ok so have you guys
already that book the seven habits of
successful people yeah all of you really
then why are you here ok no so what I
mean by this
is turns out we can learn week we can
learn things right I know there's a
saying that you can't take it teach an
old dog new tricks I don't believe that
I'm optimistic okay so the way I see it
is that you can emulate success by
having good habits by learning good
habits okay so what what what I like to
do is when I me successful people i'd
like to ask them about their lifestyle
what they do what are their secrets okay
so if you have the willingness to do
that and to go look at how other people
are successful there think their thought
patterns then you could improve yourself
in other words look look at yourself
many of us are limited in our own
success because of our own bad habits
right so how many of you actually spend
time on reflection and looking back at
your own lifestyle what bad habits you
have okay I'll just give one example do
you guys use alarm clocks to wake up in
the morning how many of you press the
snooze button right yeah you're raising
your hands like this but those of you
who know right that's that's just a bad
habit right it's just bad habit so you
know you'll save time and money and you
know you want me not save money but you
certainly save time and energy by just
waking up when you're supposed to wake
up right so the habit of using snooze
button is it may it's this time wasted
and the ANC's and the you know you have
to remember how many times you press the
snooze and what what's the real time you
have to wake up you know have to set the
alarm you know you do some math before
the night before okay I'm gonna press
news three times I had set the alarm at
this you know you're just joking around
and lying to yourself okay so that's
just small example but really I you know
I this is one of the things when I coach
and give feedback to my team members I
I'm you know it's about giving critical
feedback right I'm very I'm these days
I'm very candid I tell them
the reason you're not performing at your
peak performance is because of these bad
habits I just pointed out to them and
then I expect them to have the ability
to hold on it and to accept the feedback
and really look at that okay so uh I
can't say I know all the good habits or
I practice all the good habits but this
is something I look out for I out
whenever never meet new people I always
trying to find out what good habits they
have and see how many how much I can
copy myself okay so the last one is this
and then we'll go to Q&A so this is um
so this is kind of odd this is not very
new either write the expression that
knowing is not the same as doing do you
guys know what that means yeah knowing
so so I mean yeah of course duh no one
is not the same as doing but but what I
mean by this at the deeper level is that
too many of us especially you know yeah
I put myself in that category you know
have all these great fancy degrees at
great universities we know a lot right
at least I think I do so that's one of
our problems so so when you know too
much it actually stops you from going
out and doing it all right so the reason
I started my entrepreneurial late is
because you know I kept telling myself
oh yeah I know how to do it i took calm
buyers course how did you start yeah i
know how to do it I'm gonna go do it you
know and and the other thing was you
know big fat cushy jobs right so the
probably the worst thing that can happen
to you after you graduate or some of you
in undergrad masters yeah so so probably
going to look for jobs in a few years
right so probably the worst thing that
happened to you to be honest is to get a
fat cushy job a well paying high paying
job very comfortable because that would
just be terrible that would just be
terrible and because because it
basically you have no motivation level
you just you know you have a good salary
you know you have buy a nice car live in
a nice house you know you spend your
credit card like crazy but really go do
something right so that that's why I'm
really excited to do this big points
turbines because I it's truly something
I'm passionate about to see Bitcoin sexy
to see cryptocurrency succeed
and it's you know the pay is low but the
challenge is high through this there's
no every day is exciting but but go out
and do it right the Nike slogan just do
it I like that really go on and do it
okay it could be it doesn't matter what
but but don't get caught in the cycle
where you think you know something and
not go practice it so all the last seven
examples of the things I've learned
nothing is crazy new to any of you am i
right I didn't tell you anything crazy
new but the idea that but for me it
really hit home when actually actually
go run my own company work with real
people do projects that that aren't that
seem exciting that are exciting but but
can also be prone to failure right so
it's about hitting the real world real
customers you don't know until you do it
okay so turn knowledge into action
that's my last call out basically you
know at Stanford at great universities
wherever you are with it with uh with
college degrees we know a lot already we
learned a lot but actually go out and
practice it as opposed to being career
students right or yeah or any post Doc's
here okay all right so thank you very
much so I have I know cover a lot of
different things I love to open up for
questions uh let's go with raising your
hands okay so let's let's start here sir
in cities friction complexities in what
do we need to repeat the question for
the other okay so the question is a lot
of friction and complexities in auction
of a Bitcoin the adoption of the coin of
an accelerated actually usage how do you
accelerate adoption and usage Bitcoin
there's it's it's sort of like the
internet in 1996-97 when I graduated
from Stanford here how do you accelerate
the option of the internet it turns out
it's chicken and egg you want more users
globally and then you have more websites
and more internet companies and then
more users but
get one without the other so it happens
organically so with more ISPs with more
people coming online you have more
internet companies more apps more more
use cases more ecommerce and everything
so it's it unfortunately happens slowly
I wouldn't be surprised if it takes 5 10
20 years I don't think I'll take 20
years that much but but the single most
one of the biggest difficulties with
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies it's just
such a complicated topic I mean I didn't
go into any technical stuff today but
the vast majority of you in the audience
actually still don't know the details
intimate details of bit of Bitcoin
cryptocurrency right I talked about you
know so so basically through education
through understanding and then through
that people willing to to start using it
right so I think it's gonna take some
time we're still looking for that killer
app I think it's going to be money
payments transfers yeah okay question
over here you mentioned that Bitcoin
actually transferred smelly at the speed
of light but you also mentioned that for
many Chinese people it's a very
cumbersome process like buy bitcoins and
then send their money abroad can you
explain yes so so your question was
about Bitcoin at the 101 had become
being you know speed of light transfer
for the valley which is great but other
hand it's very cumbersome to buy buy
sell bitcoin in China it turns out
that's true that's true and in here's
irony the irony is exactly what you said
Bitcoin itself if we all had Bitcoin in
this room any sort of Commerce will be
very fast cheap you know cheaper faster
better cheaper right but the problem is
in this room only a handful of us have
Bitcoin the rest of you don't have
Bitcoin then how would the recipe by
Bitcoin you have to go through Bitcoin
exchanges right Bitcoin companies and it
turns out it's very cumbersome and the
reason it's cumbersome it's not because
a Bitcoin the reason it's cumbersome is
because the existing money system is
cumbersome so in China the the process
in on BTCC to buy Bitcoin you have to
transfer money from a bank account the
Chinese mechanism is already quite fast
but the vast slowness of it is actually
in the money transfer in the the real
currency money transferred fiat transfer
and once you get the Bitcoin
everything's really fast so the it's
where the rubber hits the road where the
friction is right so that that's
inevitable until until we're fully fully
cryptocurrency economy will always have
the existing money system US dollars
euros Chinese women be and then we'll
have the super currencies where I call
the cryptocurrencies that can happen at
speed of light okay okay question over
here sir Oh what's your thought on
Bitcoin being used like you know all the
horrible things is used for like then
abling like people would have buy
weapons and drugs and my pay like murder
people and so the question is what I
think about bitcoins being used for for
all the horrible illegal illicit
activities so another question is do you
think it will ever be society like
socially adopted if people will know
that it's enabling all those things yeah
uh what will ultimately will Bitcoin
ultimately be adopted adopted by society
knowing that there's some of the dark
web black market stuff happening I think
I think it will be here's why okay it
turns out there's a lot more US dollars
being used for illicit activities and
illegal activities right cash is the
greatest source or form the preferred
form for illicit activities we're buying
drugs you know even like murder for hire
I don't know there's there's lots of
lots of you know sex drugs and alcohol
kind of thing with with US dollars right
but does that make US dollars bad not
really right if you look at if you look
at the video wars in the 1980s many of
you too young to know this but VHS
cassette tapes yes to know what that is
VHS before DVDs these things called
cassette tapes VHS and this is a format
called Betamax apparently VHS went out
on Betamax because they support it
there's a whole you know cottage adult
porn industry that uses VHS tapes but
you know the download movies you see
today you watch today on iTunes or HBO
you know the precursor you know DVDs and
netflix and the precursor that was VHS
so we don't care about that anymore the
fact that there are pornography you know
being downloaded streaming it doesn't
affect the fact that we still enjoy live
video content or streaming video right
same thing so so Bitcoin or cash you
know people people choose to buy drugs
you know using whatever currency they
want to you know people using drugs so
so fortunately in China drug use is not
a big problem that's why people don't
use drugs akudo you speak on to buy
drugs in China but whereas I think in
the u.s. a few years ago we heard about
Silk Road the website to buy these drugs
and illicit goods and services a lot of
Pee Wee prefer to use Bitcoin right so I
think I think society is smart you know
people will use it for the right things
and people won't won't care too much
yeah okay question the gentleman in the
back ok after in the back in the way
back go ahead yeah given the big supply
of Bitcoin volatility and in particular
the general upward trend in the past few
months wouldn't you say that people are
more likely to use it like as a
speculative asset instead of a currency
you're asking you're asking about the
speculation pickle with your question
sir so like aren't they aren't they more
likely to to want to keep their Bitcoin
and wait till the price keeps going up
instead of spending it yeah we're using
it as a currency yeah that's that's a
great question so the question was if
bitcoin price keeps going off its it's
actually doubled in the last one year or
if its slopes keeps going up slowly
where people just hoard it and not spend
it and not use it for payment there is a
concern of that but I'll tell you my
answer to that problem it's actually it
comes down to where the Bitcoin whether
it comes back about whether it's easier
or not to buy sell Bitcoin companies
like us there's several in the world
many exchanges in the world who try to
make it easy for people to buy and sell
bitcoin ok if that is taken care of then
you're quite the concern you have is not
is no longer there because for example
if I have ten bitcoins that I want to
hold on to the 10 bitcoins will be worth
about 4,500 US dollars if I want to have
that as my savings for the next few
years but at the same time I may want to
pay someone in Europe
let's say 500 euros I actually don't
have to dip into my 10 bitcoins right
because if I have to pay him in Europe I
all him the money anyways so I might
have I must have the money somehow and I
can just use that to easily buy bitcoins
buy new bitcoins and then send it to the
person in Europe does that make sense so
when I need to buy coffee or breakfast
and I want to pay by bit coin it must be
because I have money to begin with so I
could use the money to instantly turn
into bitcoins by the pay for the coffee
of the breakfast and therefore I don't
need to dip into my savings yeah okay
question sir in the middle there yeah o
our game board I give you their
regulators how to view the role of
regulators for Bitcoin yeah this is very
interesting this is it turns out because
bitcoin is decentralized there is no
organization that controls Bitcoin
however many many countries i would say
every country in the world will have to
regulate bitcoin and it's in their
interest because bitcoin is a real deal
bitcoin is a real financial asset it
just happens to be digital they can't
touch your feel except for this cool
thing here right but they will have to
regulate it because because we deal with
real money real value right for consumer
protection for proper finance and
economic reasons they have to regulate
it so it's also new in the sense that
many of the department's trying to
regulate are not qualified don't have
the experience to do it so so today
every country we have regulators in
finance and in stock market in
commodities housing market real estate
taxation you know insurance regulation
and stuff like that but none of them
deal with not only truly qualified to
regulate digital currencies so I expect
countries will start having departments
that actually are catered towards
digital currencies because it's like so
different yeah so I look forward to that
day happening i think it's already
happening the state of New York has
already issued DFS Department initial
services are issued bit license from
companies to apply and get so New York
State has it united states
we'll soon have it nationwide and other
countries will also have that so it's
going to come in the next three to five
years okay question here there's less
regulation in China in comparison to
America or Europe on taxation and the
lead to get yeah yeah so so regulation
for Bitcoin in China the questions about
is there less or more regulation child
it turns out china is actually very
friendly i didn't mention inside china
is actually very friendly with become
regulation even though they talked about
it in 2013 they talked about having
different swimming lanes for bitcoin and
financial solutions it or not it's
pretty simple it's pretty easy they did
pretty encouraging of it at least they
don't they don't block this block is
completely so so BTCC has thrived in
China over the last few years many other
Bitcoin companies have emerged in China
the interest is there and also that
because the regulators are doing using a
lace a fair approach they're saying you
know well let's see how it develops and
if we need to will will come and
regulate it down the road yeah that's
how it is okay question sir I'd like to
know more about the 21 billion figure
why was it chosen what keeps it from
being a expanded how why aren't there
more than 20 1,000,000,000 yes so I
bring a little bit oh yes yes I'll talk
about the big so the question is about
the limit of Bitcoin how many 21 million
so it's actually 21 million and not 21
billion so the question is how why is it
there and so on so it turns out the 21
million figure was was set in stone by
by the Creator Satoshi Nakamoto it
wasn't picked out of thin air so he had
a certain algorithm remember he is it's
that free lottery right so we he wanted
to do was do a lottery every 10 minutes
every hour 66 drawings six surprises in
our each prize being 50 bitcoins so
those were arbitrary he won a six per
hour he won a 50 / / / drawing so that
was 300 bitcoins per one hour so that
was arbitrary if you take the 30 new
bitcoins per hour and then you do that
for four years and then you what he did
was every four years just like the
Olympics or the world cup soccer he
decide to cut down by half only by
cutting down in half he could he could
sort of do this exponential logarithmic
delay where
Chile gets to 21 million bitcoins so the
math just works out right that half of
Bitcoin comes out in the first four
years so if you do if you do that math
7,000 your bitcoins per per day you do
four years of that you get exactly 10
and a half million roughly yeah and then
that's half of all the bitcoins and then
the next four years you get the other
half the half of the half the the next
four years you get half of what's left
of that and so on so on and so on so
eventually the prize today is 25
bitcoins in two months the prize will be
12 and a half in four years the prize
will be 6.25 and there will be 3.125 and
then we'll be like 1.5 1.6 something
keep throwing down until it gets down to
0.5 0.25 0.125 all youtube 0.000000 01
so that's 140 years later it turns out
so take it it's gonna take another
hundred years for all that for the last
few bits to come out okay so when you
add that all together it's kind of like
this calculus math thing you add up the
certain to sum up the area under the
curve whatever and then you get 21
million bitcoins so that's it and then
how is it kept why is it only 21 million
because it's a consensus system so the
whole world actually runs a software
Bitcoin protocol and then they all self
unfortunately reinforced each other they
say my version is softer I run I say I
insist there shall be more not more than
21 million bitcoins and if everyone runs
the same software we all force the rest
of the world to say not more than 21
million so that's why there's that's why
it's 21 million it's enforced because if
you think about it if you own Bitcoin
would you want there to be more than 21
million or exactly if you have your
bitcoins you don't want you wouldn't you
refuse to run the software that says 22
million the other problem is if you
actually have softer this as 22 million
who gets the extra 1 million Bitcoin
right would you say you get it yourself
if you did that will the rest of us
agree we're like no way so we won't
agree with you so that's why it's called
the consensus blockchain yeah okay one
more question ok out in the back very
back they're convenient way to hedge
against volatility because if someone
has a check
and cow they don't want to have ten
percent less money next week yes so the
question is is there way too good way to
hedge against volatility that's a great
question and I think it's taking a few
years for us for the industry to come to
that turns out we do now you know btcc
one of the products we offer is called
the pro exchange it's a professional
exchange where people can easily buy
sell go long and go short with Bitcoin
and use that to hedge the price risk of
Bitcoin so if your own bitcoins if you
own ten bitcoins you want to lock it up
at 450 US dollars you could then do a
derivative contract by selling short can
bitcoins on contract so you only 10
bitcoins you sell that and no matter if
you come price goes up or down you
always have four thousand five hundred
dollars yeah so there there that's going
to be more it's just started we just
launched that late last year but these
kinds of things will come into the
marketplace very very soon to make it
more available to everyone okay so
bitcoin bitcoin is a complex topic thank
you for for coming over here and giving
the opportunity to share with everyone